alors on va prendre quelques questions
de la salle
peut-être je peux demander en attendant
un marc philippe daubresse qui a les
compétences que l'on connaît sur le
logement de nous dire quelles sont les
grandes la grande architecture d'une
autre politique en faveur du logement
qui est un sujet évidemment très
important pour nos concitoyens
marc-philippe oui luc nous avons fait
comme première convention de toutes
celles qui ont fait larchitecture de ce
nouveau projet une convention sur le
logement c'était la volonté de nicolas
sarkozy de montrer concrètement comment
on pouvait relancer l'économie française
avec des emplois créés et non
délocalisables et avec une politique qui
change radicalement par rapport à celle
qui est menée par le gouvernement actuel
qui a conduit je le rappelle à ce qu'on
passe de 480 milles construction neuve
par an sous nicolas sarkozy à 300000
construction neuve par an on abaissait
de 50% la production construction neuve
dans ce pays sans parler des logements
sociaux qui sont financés mois que sous
le quinquennat précédent
comment peut-on lancer le logement par
un plan orsec nous estimons qu'il faut
vraiment enlever toutes les machines
empêché de faire et libérer les énergies
et essayer de faire un effet levier avec
toutes les forces vives qui peuvent
contribuer au logement dans ce pays un
en abrogeant la loi allure la loi
allures de madame duflot
ça a été un signal de défiance sa
empêcher les investisseurs d'investir
sans empêcher les constructeurs de
construire sa empêcher toute une série
d'opérations de se réaliser
nous voulons abroger cette loi et nous
voulons refonder autre chose
nous voulons d'abord aller vers plus de
production parce qu'on on ne sortira du
problème du logement qu'avec plus de
production ça suppose d'agir sur le
foncier en libérant des terrans ça
suppose d'agir sur la fiscalité
nous voulons prioriser les primo
accédants à la propriété avec une tva à
5,5 de manière à ce qu'on dise bien que
le parcours résidentiel dont parle la
gauche et un parcours d'ascenseur c'est
pas toboggan
qui fait descendre tout le monde vers le
bas c'est pas le nivellement par le bas
c'est au contraire d'essayer de faire
progresser l'ensemble de nos
compatriotes nous voulons refonder la
loi sru sur le logement social qui est
une loi coercitive qui pénalise les
communes sur un stock de logements
nous voulons que ce qu'on puisse
raisonner en pourcentage de logements
conventionnés sur des flux de logements
et non pas sur des stocks
nous voulons que on arrête de traiter de
logement social des logements des
offices publics dash-l m
un logement il est social en fonction
des personnes qui l'habitent et pas en
fonction du financement qui a permis de
le réaliser
et ça change tout parce que ça permet
d'intégrer tout le parc locatif privé
dans cette dynamique là et nous avons
besoin du parc locatif privé
je rappelle pour ceux qui ne le
sauraient pas que quand on prend les
populations les plus pauvres de france
une majorité d'entre elles ne sont pas
dans le parc public hlm mais dans le
parc locatif privé
d'où la nécessité d'aider les
investisseurs locatifs
la nécessité d'arrêter de bloquer les
choses de permettre d'expulser plus
rapidement les mauvais payeurs d'arrêter
toutes les procédures d'encadrement des
loyers comme ce que madame kosyam faire
dans la région parisienne on voulait
encadrer les loyers au raréfient l'offre
si on rares et filant forcément à terme
les loyers augmentent
nous ne voulons plus de ces machines
empêché de faire nous voulons relancer
l'ensemble du dispositif et eric woerth
a juste dit nous dit attention les
finances c'est important nous voulons
des recettes supplémentaires nous
obligeront à vendre 2 % du parc hlm pour
que les offices et laisse à dalhem
bénéficie dette de l'état
si on veut que l'état aide les offices
et laisse hadash hellemmes
il faut en contrepartie qu'on permette
de vendre une partie du parc du locatif
qui devient accession c'est aussi la
garantie d'un bon parcours résidentiel
et sa renfloue les caisses c'est donc
tout à fait utile nous voulons agir sur
le parc privé anciens parce que c'est
bon pour les artisans qui rénovent ce
pas c'est bon pour les locataires qui
ont des charges de chauffage moins
lourdes et c'est bon pour
l'environnement
même temps et nous voulons aussi arrêter
cette inflation de normes qui empêche de
faire si l'une des premières mesures
sera de faire un moratoire sur les
normes et mieux de supprimer une série
de normes qui empêchent de construire du
logement
quand des maires veulent bâtir
aujourd'hui on les empêche le faire on
fait des recours abusifs et on a toute
une série de dispositifs coercitif
il faut renverser la vapeur il faut
inciter
il faut encourager et il faut permettre
aux investisseurs
ollo privé locatif avec un statut du
bailleur privé locatif et à l'ensemble
du parc du logement de se redresser
nous l'avons fait je le dis parce qu'on
dit tout ça c'est des programmes yab un
peu plus de dix ans nous avons lancé
sous jacques chirac
les prémices d'un premier plan ensuite
sous nicolas sarkozy il ya eu un second
plan on a augmenté de 50 % la
construction dans le pays
on a triplé l'accession à la propriété
dans le pays
on a doublé le financement du logement
locatif social ne pouvons le faire et ça
créera des emplois
merci marc philippe alors on prend une
question micro bleus je veux saluer
l'arrivée de notre premier ministre
edouard balladur microbes le bien volé
je suis maire d or conseiller national
maire d'une commune de 550 habitants qui
gère une station de sports de montagne
quinze mille lits qui amène 80 millions
d'euros 2
de retombées économiques et 800 emplois
la réforme territoriale aujourd'hui
renforcent considérablement le pouvoir
et les compétences des intercommunalités
avec une vision que je dirais
métropolitaine et très administrative
qui peut amener à des incohérences je
prends deux exemples la commune que je
dont j'ai la responsabilité apportera 34
% de la fiscalité net économique de du
futur pc que nous sommes en train de
caen tout de construire et nous aurons
une place parmi 38 au conseil
communautaire la loi notre aussi
transfert de la compétence tourisme à
l'intercommunalité moi j'ai en charge
une entreprise qui vend 500 mille
journées skieurs par an et donc dans le
cadre d'une intercommunalité c'est trop
compliqué en ce que je veux dire
simplement c'est que la voix de la
rationalisation est incontournable mais
que nous ne ne vont pas détruire ce qui
fonctionne aujourd'hui ni détruire aussi
les énergies de proximité et donc ma
question c'est quelle place pour la
commune dans notre projet merci pour
cette question je voudrais rebondir sur
ta question pour être l'élu d'un
département rural
nous vivons tous il y en a un certain
nombre tour de la table ce qui se passe
et que tu viens de décrire
c'est à dire qu'en moins de trois ans le
gouvernement a réussi à faire sauter
tous les repères avec les communes
nouvelles qui sont en train d'inventer
avec les nouvelles intercommunalités
avec des périmètres imposée au forceps
par les préfets sur des coins de table
souvent pour des raisons politiques avec
des nouveaux cantons qui là aussi ont
été découpés sur un coin de table et
dont on a bien souvent oublié l'idée du
bassin de vie avec ces nouvelles régions
jeu j'appartiens à une région j'étais
élu d'un département la haute-marne je
suis élu mais dans un département qui
était le petit département d'une petite
région nous sommes maintenant mon cher
philippe dans avec françois baroin dans
une grande région
est lorraine alsace champagne-ardenne
c'est très compliqué voilà donc on voit
bien que il y a une volonté d'éloigner
le pouvoir de décision de le diluer de
mettre en place des technostructures
pour faire en sorte que le pouvoir
échappe aux élus et bien sûr cette
question nous avons pris des positions
très claires nous voulons une
organisation territoriale qui soit un
retour au conseiller territorial que
nous avions fait voter sous le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy qui était
une vraie avancée avec un élu qui
appartient à la fois l'assemblée
départementale et l'assemblée régionale
et au cas par cas je pense que nicolas
sarkozy en parlera au cas par cas nous
aurons à revoir cette carte cette
organisation c'est vrai que c'est
difficile parce que d'un côté
y compris dans la salle il y en a
beaucoup qui disent écoutez ça fait cinq
ans qu'on est dans des réorganisations
qu'on n'arrête pas de nous changer de
communauté de communes de région et
autres on a envie de se poser et
d'autres qui disent à juste titre aussi
ça peut pas marcher
il faut revoir les choses et remettre la
carte territoriale à plat donc on a un
peu à gérer ses contradictions
je pense que la proposition qui est dans
notre projet qui repart du conseiller
territorial qui repart de la proximité
qui repart de la commune est la bonne
alors je voudrais donner la parole à
guillaume larrivé qui vous le savez
travaille beaucoup sur les questions
d'organisation de gouvernance et je
voudrais lui céder la parole
merci luc la grande question au fond qui
nous est posée quand on parle
d'institutions c est ce qu'on sera
capable de faire le job en 2017 si les
français nous donne la majorité
notre première idée c'est naturellement
d'avoir les idées claires sur le projet
avant l'exercice du pouvoir et c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on est fier
d'avoir ce document de plus de 300 pages
qui indique très précisément sur toutes
les questions qu'elles seraient les
réformes on veut
le contraire de ce qu'avait fait
françois hollande c'est à dire d'arriver
au pouvoir comme une poule devant un
couteau sans savoir quoi faire de son
propre pouvoir
mais ce que nous refusons aussi ça
serait le bricolage constitutionnel
nous tenons à la vème république nous
tenons aux équilibres des institutions
de la vème république qui ont résisté à
bien des épreuves
la dernière épreuve d'ailleurs ce sont
les quatre années de françois hollande
même avec un président de la république
aussi faible aussi incertain de ses
intentions aussi incapable de diriger
l'état la vème république résiste alors
dans ce cadre de la 5ème république
que voulons-nous faire deux choses deux
choses très simples et très forte
d'abord il faut que le gouvernement
gouverne et prennent la main sur la
technostructure ce n'est pas
l'administration qui dirige les
ministres ce sont les ministres qui
doivent diriger les administrations et
qui doivent donc regard des très
précisément ce qui est fait par les
bureaux en disant cela je n'attaque pas
les fonctionnaires j'en étais un
moi-même je pense que chacun doit rester
à sa place il ya le pouvoir politique
désignés par le peuple et ya les
fonctionnaires qui doivent mettre en
oeuvre les décisions du gouvernement
c'est la première réforme la deuxième
réforme que nous espérons pouvoir mener
sous l'impulsion de nicolas sarkozy si
le peuple français ne décide ce sera une
évolution du format et du rôle du
parlement
il ya aujourd'hui mes amis plus de mille
députés français à l'assemblée nationale
député français au parlement européen
sénateur au au sénat plus de 1000 nous
pensons qu'en étant moins nombreux sans
doute moins nombreux d'un tiers
on peut être plus efficace mieux
organisés plus engagé au service de la
france et des français
c'est pour ça que je suis très fier et
je le dis comme jeune député je suis
très fier que dans le projet des
républicains que vous soumet que nous
soumet aujourd'hui nicolas sarkozy y est
cette idée extrêmement forte d'un
référendum dès juin 2010 est pour
refonder l'organisation du parlement
avec environ 400 députés au lieu de 577
et environ 200 sénateurs au lieu je
crois de 348
alors oui à la vème république une
cinquième république qui assume ce
qu'elle ait un gouvernement qui gouverne
un parlement qui légifère avec
efficacité avec envie avec énergie au
service des français
merci merci guillaume alors je vais
maintenant donner la parole à notre
secrétaire général eric woerth ce qui va
nous présenter les grandes lignes de
notre projet et à l'issue de son
intervention
je mettrai aux voix le projet des
républicains